bambino non avevo la più pallida idea
che nella mia vita avrei fatto le
scalate ma quando ritrovato nei miei
archivi questa foto
forse ho cominciato a capire che in
realtà dentro di me c'era una certa
naturalezza nell'affrontare le
altitudini e la scalata siamo a matera
la città dei sassi
quindi non potevo parlare non potevo non
parlarvi della prima scalata che ho
fatto nella mia vita cioè un masso in
dolomiti e quando sono arrivato in vetta
questo masso ho cominciato a rendermi
conto che questa attività mi piaceva
cioè il fatto di alzare la mano verso la
vetta anche se quello era un masso
piccolissimo mi comincio a dare quella
sensazione di voler salire verso le
vette del mondo solo che all'epoca non
avevo la più pallida idea di che cosa
fosse la paura o vincere sulle montagne
o anche fallire proprio perché in quel
momento quando sei giovane
a queste cose non ci pensi non si
accumulano nel tuo vivere e quindi è più
facile affrontare le vite la vita e
soprattutto le sfide poi a un certo
punto mentre cresce
c'è sempre un genitore i genitori o
qualche amico che ti prende per mano e
ti accompagna attraverso le esperienze
queste esperienze che nel mio caso
furono accompagnate dalla mano di mio
padre che mi aiutò a superare le prime
paure attraverso la sua conoscenza la
sua abilità ea portarmi in vetta ai
monti lepini di 1.536 metri e pensate in
pieno inverno immaginate che i monti
lepini sono delle montagne che si
affacciano sulla pianura pontina e dove
di fronte tu puoi vedere il tirreno con
l'isola con le isole pontine da ponza
ventotene
questo per dirvi che la distanza di dove
vivo perché questo luogo dove vivo con
le grandi montagne è veramente una
grande distanza era difficile per me
avere maestri che potessero aiutarmi ad
avere quella conoscenza che mi potesse
permettere di scalare è sempre meglio ed
affrontare le grandi sfide
quando a un certo punto mi sono accorto
però che caspita crescevo e la montagna
mi piaceva sempre di più
allora mi sono detto caspita ma forse
posso ambire anche a scalare pareti
sempre più verticali
di roccia e di ghiaccio però quel punto
la manina di papà che mi accompagnava
per non farmi inciampare nella vita a
quel punto mi aveva mollato e per cui
con un po di difficoltà sono riuscito in
qualche modo ad affrontare queste pareti
farete consigli mi permettessero di
capire come fare e in automatico in
maniera quasi naturale mi era
approcciato all'arrampicata su roccia
avevo cominciato a scalare le prime
parete fu un attimo per passare da
queste pareti di roccia a mettere
insieme un po di coraggio e in maniera
anche un po incosciente o inconsapevole
a 18 anni riesca arrivare sulla vetta
italiana sul monte bianco 4.810 metri
allora provate a immaginare un ragazzino
che vive sulla pianura pontina in un
paese dove le montagne al massimo
arrivano a 1500 metri che a un certo
punto si ritrova a scalare il suo primo
albero il suo primo sasso la sua prima
parete la sua prima vetta di 4000 m il
monte bianco è un certo punto si dice
caspita una se è così facile perché non
andare sulla montagna di 8.000 metri e
qui subentrano i problemi perché un
ragazzo che viene dalla pianura pontina
da un paese che si chiama sezze in
provincia di latina
cosa ne può sapere di come si respira a
7000 metri a 8.000 metri
cosa fa l'assenza di ossigeno a quella
quota all'organismo umano e alla tua
motivazione riesce a trovare il coraggio
per metterti in movimento quando
coraggio viene definito come forza
d'animo necessaria per affrontare
un'impresa difficile o pericolosa
e infatti proprio in quel periodo
successe qualcosa che io non avevo
calcolato sia sul gasherbrum ii di 8.000
45 metri ma anche sul foglio di 8.200
metri
daniele nardi fallisce sul gasherbrum mi
fermo a 7 mila metri sul so io arrivo
8.050 metri da un centinaio di metri
dalla vetta comincia a congelare solo
costretta ridiscendere allora sapete
nella prima spedizione al gasherbrum
dico caspita riesco ad andare
in quota comincia a capire come funziona
coordinarsi con una squadra con i tuoi
alpinisti con i portatori con la gente
che è lì inizia a capire un po come
funzionano queste spedizioni
poi a un certo punto arrivi a 7.000
l'ossigeno svanisce entri nella zona
della morte dove potrebbero svilupparsi
proprio per la carenza di ossigeno ed
emi a livello cerebrale o polmonare che
potrebbero portare alla morte
quindi ho cominciato attraverso questa
esperienza a capire cosa significava
andare a 8.000 metri o almeno a 7.000
successivamente acciaio ridiscendo
perché avevo fatto degli errori semplici
avevo lasciato i miei piedi dentro lo
scarpone di notte quindi l'umidità aveva
fatto sì che poi a 20 gradi sotto zero i
piedi si congelassero e anche altri
errori che tecnicamente è diciamo è è
quasi inutile spiegarlo perché sarebbe
complicato però è per dire che anche al
so io mi ero portato a casa un
esperienza ma era successa una cosa
cominciava ad avere paura di fallire
nuovamente non era più come quando
avevano scalato la mia prima montagna la
mia prima parete di roccia a un certo
punto comincia ad aver paura non tanto
di intraprendere una nuova sfida sulle
montagne ma soprattutto di fallire e che
cosa accade a quel punto che cominciai a
rendermi conto che nel processo di di
vittoria rispetto a quella paura c'era
un processo molto interessante cioè
quello di riuscire in qualche modo a
capitalizzare la mia esperienza tirar
fuori delle conoscenze che potevano in
qualche modo aiutarmi a ritrovare quella
forza vitale detta anche come coraggio
come abbiamo definito prima per poter
partire per nuove imprese in fondo dal
gas rubrum avevo capito come affrontare
l'alta quota al ciò io avevo capito come
gestire un team soprattutto come non
congelare o comunque come combattere
congelamenti fatto sta che queste due
cose insieme
in qualche modo mi aiutano a trovare il
coraggio per andare all'everest e il 19
maggio del 2004 riesco ad arrivare in
vetta gli 8.850 metri dell'everest
in fondo cominciava a uscire fuori una
consapevolezza dentro di me che fa paura
esperienze capitalizzate e ripartire di
nuovo quindi trovare il coraggio per
fare nuove sfide c'era un collegamento
veramente molto sottile
infatti ogni volta che io vincevo aveva
una vittoria su una montagna in fondo
che cosa facevo andava a cercare di
capire ciò che io avevo fatto di buono
per raggiungere l'obiettivo e lo
capitalizzava quindi quelle esperienze
era una conoscenza che avrei potuto
riapplicare allo stesso modo però quando
fallì ho sbagliato qualcosa che cosa
accadeva che di nuovo tornavo indietro a
guardare ciò che era accaduto ciò che
avevo sbagliato per come esperienza
proprio farla mia al fine di poter
trovare nuove soluzioni di applicarle ma
con una grande differenza se è vero che
quando vinci capisce una strategia che
può funzionare quando perdi il
meccanismo di comprendere ciò che è
accaduto è molto più sottile e delicato
oltre che è difficoltoso perché perché è
vero che puoi rianalizzare ciò che è
sbagliato per usarlo per il futuro
ma se tu non fai in modo che questa
esperienza si trasformi in conoscenza e
quindi la poi riapplicare potresti
bloccarti ed è quello che per poco non
capitava all'everest
vi racconto un altro aneddoto mi trovo a
7200 metri su una montagna dal nome
makalu ormai erano giorni che eravamo lì
insieme ai miei due compagni di cordata
arriviamo in questo posto e purtroppo
succede che l'alta quota
li produce dei sintomi un po strani
l'inizio essere disorientato faccio
fatica a camminare a respirare e non
solo più molto lucido
era il momento in cui avremmo dovuto
tentare di scalare la vetta ma non
voglio rovinare la spedizione mia ai
miei compagni di cordata allora li
lascio andare e da questi 7.200 metri
che sia già nella zona della morte dove
l'organismo umano proprio per l'assenza
di ossigeno a quelle quote non riesce a
sopravvivere facilmente quindi gli dico
ragazzi voi andate e io scenderò verso
valle perché c'è qualcosa che non va
senza specificare
feci un grave errore anche lì perché non
era supportato dall'esperienza e non
avevo mai avuto quel problema ed era
difficile capire come si fa senza
ausilio supplementare di bombole di
ossigeno a vivere così tanto a quelle
quote e può capitare qualche volta senza
lucidità metto i ramponi ai piedi che
sono quegli attrezzi che si mettono
sotto gli scarponi per scalare su
ghiaccio immaginate si scivola allora
hanno delle punte che si incastrano nei
ghiacci loro vanno verso la vetta e
arriveranno in vetta io comincio la
discesa e vado verso valle per essere
più veloce non porto con me la piccozza
questo attrezzo che si attacca al
ghiaccio che si usa con le mani lascio
lo zaino mia vinchio alla corda e
comincia a scendere velocemente verso
valle
a un certo punto il rampone da sotto i
piedi si stacca scivolo sul ghiaccio
questa parete di ghiaccio che mi porta
verso la zona di salvezza volo per 20
metri riesca a rimanere agganciato alla
corda ea quel punto mi trovo fermo su
questa parete consapevole che se fosse
rimasto lì sarei morto
ero disperato anche preso un po dal
panico a dire la verità perché non
sapevo più quello che fare
ci fu un momento che ancora una volta
quella specie di comprensione di
illuminazione che aveva avuto a quel
punto mi viene in aiuto cioè riesca a
capire che in quel momento se fossi se
continuassi a farmi prendere dal panico
ha magari a non voler reagire oppure a
rimanere lì disperato probabilmente
sarei morto l'unica speranza che avevo
dopo aver compreso questo era rischiare
il tutto per tutto e traversare quel
tratto di ghiaccio che mi separava da
una zona più facile per poter scendere
dove potevo scendere anche senza un
rampone riesco a farlo dicendo i 1.700
metri e arrivò finalmente al campo base
lì sono in salvo
allora io non so che questo è un esempio
veramente estremo però vi faccio una
domanda è possibile che nella vita di
tutti i giorni quando affrontiamo le
nostre sfide sede che potrebbero
sembrare di tutti i giorni
noi viviamo delle piccole sfide estreme
dove in realtà magari non mettiamo
proprio a repentaglio la nostra vita
come nell'alpinismo che è uno sport
estremo
ma però non si dice ma dico in quel
momento è come se noi se falliamo
perdiamo un po di autostima
perdiamo un pochettino di noi stessi
quando sbagliamo nella vita ed è questo
che mi capita a volte quando mi capita
di sbagliare proprio nella vita ma può
essere un lavoro può essere
nell'educazione dei figli può essere in
qualsiasi cosa mi sembra di perdere
qualcosa e quindi questo può essere per
certi versi come praticamente il
nell'ambito alpinistico estremo
possa fare benissimo
come insoliti si sa può
le attese mendes
kelly
one man in black
fini sin da monte danga parbat in pieno
inverno immaginate che esistono 14
montagne di oltre 8.000 metri tutte
scalate in piena estate per tre anni
consecutivi cerco di fare un record che
non è mai stato fatto
di queste 14 montagne di 8.000 metri ben
due mais calate in pieno inverno
una di queste due nanga parbat ma perché
non è mai stata scalata d'inverno perché
a 4000 metri di parete e in una zona
geografica dove i venti possa soffiare
anche a 200 chilometri orari
ci sono tra i 50 e 60 gradi sotto zero e
le pareti sono veramente rivide il primo
anno riesco ad arrivare a 6.400 metri
fallisco secondo anno vado in solitaria
perché non riesca a trovare i compagni
di cordata per affrontare una sfida così
impegnativa fallisco di nuovo arrivo al
terzo anno cioè quello di due mesi fa e
un'altra volta riesco a salire con due
compagni di cordata arrivo a 7.830 m
considerate che questa parete di 4.000
metri abbiamo scalato i primi 3.600 ne
mancavano solo 300 ma quando siamo
arrivati lassù
abbiamo deciso di scendere e siamo
arrivati verso il campo base
quando arrivò a quell'altitudine mi
chiedo caspita sto fallendo un'altra
volta
un altro fallimento tre volte
consecutive ce la farà a riprendermi da
questo fallimento è lì compare la vetta
come se fosse la sirena che ti ammalia e
che ti vuole verso la vetta ma riesca a
vincere perché avevo l'esperienza di
quell'anno in cui il led ma cerebrale
creava dei problemi e questi sintomi che
vi avevo sprigionerà spiegato prima li
riconosco in alì alì non stava più bene
e in quel momento decidiamo di scendere
ancora una volta l'esperienza
trasformata in conoscenza mi aveva
permesso di vincere non sulla montagna
perché non eravamo arrivati in vetta al
nanga parbat
ma è certo che l'esperienza trasformata
in conoscenza mi aveva dato la forza di
forse non vincere sulla montagna ma in
qualche modo fare in modo che la
montagna non si fosse portato via le
nostre vite
grazie